christina heck is engaged to boyfriend
joshua hall the flip of flop star
announced the exciting news on instagram
monday when you know you know christina
shared romantic photos with her new
fiance enjoying a sunset dinner in los
cabos mexico where they're currently
celebrating his birthday the hgtv host
captioned the post with five emojis a
heart an infinity sign a lock a key
and a ring check out this close-up shot
of christina's stunning sparkler the
ring and her big smile are truly her
best accessories it's also worth noting
christina's instagram bio now reads
engaged to josh hall i feel very
grateful to be where i am today
just days before the engagement
christina took to instagram to share a
sweet birthday tribute to josh here's
the couple on the beach and in the
caption the mom of three wrote happy
birthday baby you give me that teenage
kind of love and manly protection it's a
combo for a lifetime of happiness and
success and a source tells et that this
engagement comes as no surprise to
christina's friends quote christina
loves love and enjoys being in a
committed relationship she's having a
great time with josh and they are so in
love and excited about this next chapter
they love experiencing new things
together traveling and going on
adventures it's amazing it is it's
incredible christina and josh were first
linked back in july one month after her
divorce from ant anstead was finalized
she later revealed that the two had been
dating for months writing in an
instagram post when we met this past
spring the synchronicities hit us so
hard and fast they were impossible to
ignore i think that
you know things happen for a reason
christina's marriage to josh will be her
third before she married ant in 2018 the
hgtv star was previously married to
tarek al-musa from 2009 to 2018.
christina shares two-year-old son hudson
with aunt and ten-year-old daughter
taylor and six-year-old son braden with
tarek it's been great the kids are such
different ages but they get along so
well christina and tarek also continue
to co-parent and work together on their
hit home renovation show flip a flop
you're an inspiration to a lot of
blended families are there times where
you have to step back and be like this
is really not what i want to do but it's
best for the kids of course yeah of
course okay
i think any divorce family deals with
that kind of stuff and sometimes you
know things can be difficult but at the
end of the day like the kids love to see
all of us together all the time so
that's that's what works while tarek and
christina have co-parenting down packed
it is still new for her ex-husband and
who opened up to et last month
ultimately the the concept of blended
families is more common now than
than it was and you know we live in a
society now where
it's uh it's more normal it just has to
come from a place of love really because
ultimately if the uh the decision is in
favor of the child is ultimately the
right decision and you know i've seen so
many um you know families and parents
co-parent badly
and it's a real shame because ultimately
when all that
you know that uh
i guess awkwardness fails away which it
will do eventually time's a great healer
you're only going to get an opportunity
to look back and when you look back and
you say how did i handle my side how did
i handle my half and uh you know i'm
really proud of
really proud of my heart
you